every morning begins with a roll call
fark is still in charge here 70 fighters
delivered this camp in the jungle a
two-day trip from the capital Bogota
Patricia is one of them she grew up in a
village and joined the guerrillas at 18
out of conviction she wanted to fight
the government which she felt was
responsible for deep and widespread
rural poverty now the fighters are going
to surrender their weapons me before
life this is my pistol me Adam we're not
we your winner and becomes part of you
you come to love it because it has been
your companion for such a long time
we're here Yahweh or so yes it hurts to
give it up on you like a thump olimpica
no no no no a little okay a hard life
FARC now wants to turn itself into a
legitimate political party how the
fighters that are reintegrate into
society is a topic of discussion at the
National guerrillas conference being
held right next to patrizia scamp farms
leaders are in attendance as well as
hundreds of its fighters from all over
the country FARC only wants to issue an
apology for a few specific acts of
violence not for its entire 52 year
struggle we know that the simple and
honest people who know us and see us
every day have a very different picture
of us in their hearts than the one
peddled by the media in the service of
the oligarchy videos Shannon visual in
early on here many fighters are tired of
war most have never known their country
at peace
de fighters are quite happy that this
war is coming to an end but on the other
hand there's quite a lot of insecurities
about what will happen in the future how
they will reinter great how they will
make the disarmament happen and these
are exactly the points that a political
leaders will discuss here during the
next couple of days the frog fighters
that I met they say they're not sorry
for anything they say they don't have to
apologize for anything so they will keep
on fighting for the same ideals they had
before so now it's just with political
means instead of arms life in the jungle
camps will soon be over for FARC
patrizia wants to go home to her village
and have children but first the fighters
will have to spend some time in un
supervised transitional zones for
normalization and other reason is to
protect them from attacks from other
armed groups quisiera is a look at you
they say oh I would like to have a
family many of us would dokely resto de
gente que de me laisser but there needs
to be guarantees that our children will
have a better future well a decent life
Malaysian mañana and won't have to
suffer the way we did necesario para
vida no killer talk is already looking
in their philosophy FARC is still in
control in many areas but if the peace
process proves successful its banners
will soon disappear along with its
jungle outposts